You recommend using protein zine powder for the, I do not like it, these recommended effective substitute for protein zine in capsule or tablet form.
Well, the problem with taking a protein powder in itself is that I don't I don't think taking a protein powder is as good as just eating some protein.
Because you can have two scoops of a protein powder that you still need to get maybe 20 to 25 grams of protein.
So, well, that's good, you know, if you're eating a smoothie, anyhow, you can throw that in there.
So, it's great. Now, you know, I always take my smoothie, maybe daily.
And so if I add the protein powder, I'm just getting protein. So, it's hard for me to eat the piece of chicken, you know, at that same time because my stomach's full.
And then you add the protein powder, it's not going to make you any more fun.
The problem with putting a capsule for two scoops or a scoop of protein powder, any, even that would be 10 capsules, you know, so I don't, you know, there may be some protein powders that come in capsule form, but you have to take a lot of capsules to be equivalent. So I will look for you for that.
The protein side is in vanilla or chocolate.
The other protein powders that I think are good, we carry one from designs for health, I think is good.
It doesn't taste any, I mean, I know all of them have the same flavor.
So, I don't know if you'll find one that you would like as far as powder goes.